you want something to eat
yeah something that's from a clean bowl
yeah
yeah well i can order something
i know you don't want to eat you have
enough money for that
the
disrespect
some of y'all missed the drama well
it's back but this is completely
unacceptable
below tests sheida to see if she just
wants him for his money by picking her
up from the airport in a van that's not
his and taking her to his modest
childhood home
just to see that if i did live here will
you still be with me i know kind of
petty but at the same time it was a
smart move because unfortunately chida
shows her true character
is there any rocks in the kitchen a lot
of what she said was actually more
hurtful than relates to like i thought
that like you would have been better
than what you are right now
welp he got the answer he was looking
for
let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicio
i know we are still getting acclimated
to this new cast
i saw some mixed reviews about kobe and
emily on last week's recap
and this week i'm so interested in
hearing your thoughts on bilal and
shaida
aside from you giving your take on them
as a couple their storyline made me
think of a question i want to know if
you had to choose between true love that
last or financial wealth that last what
would your choice be
you can only pick one
let me know in the comments and then
really think about this don't just go
with financial wealth because of
societal pressures
my name is bilal i'm 42 years old and i
live in kansas city missouri
all right let's get into bilal and
shaida quick background info
bilal works in real estate he's pretty
well off financially he has a nice home
and he drives a mercedes-benz
but he comes from humble beginnings i do
appreciate nice things
nice suits
love watches
however at the end of the day you know i
didn't grow up in a suburb i grew up in
a hood that really makes me who i am
something else that makes bilal who he
is is his muslim faith this is really
the center of who i am is the root of
what makes bilal
bilal has been divorced from his ex-wife
who he is still close with for seven
years and they share two children
together now let's get into his fiancee
chyda
she's 37 years old
she's a yoga instructor
and she's from trinidad and tobago
these two met the good old 90 day
fashion way
online
below said they had some mutual friends
on social media and she slid into his
dms
now i am here for a woman shooting her
shot but after his ex-wife said this how
do you guys meet
really just through social media brother
i know you be on facebook flexing and
all that i really don't yeah you really
do and how we're about to see shaida
behave
i'm wondering what is it about bilal
that truly made her interested
and we were talking and things were
reviving well and then i was like i have
to see you i have to see you in person
and that's when i made plans to to visit
her after talking to shadow for a while
over the phone bilal went to meet her in
person for the first time in trinidad
and after spending only seven days
physically together he proposed
it's 90 day people it's 90 day
and get this due to covet and the visa
process it's been almost two years since
they've seen each other
now they're about to live together and
get married
sounds a little weird
mm-hmm it is
anyway
because bilal has trust issues from his
past he comes up with this master plan
to pick shaida up from the airport in a
van that's not his
she told me she's a ride or die so let's
put that to the test and take her to his
childhood home in the hood
to see if she really loves him for who
he is or what he has
an important note here throughout the
entire time they've been talking bilal
has never shown her where he lives or
the car he drives
all she's seen is a blank white wall
when they video chat which if i were in
her shoes that would concern me for sure
but i'm guessing she still decided to
come to america without seeing where
she's going to live because she figured
below has money based off his facebook i
know you'd be on facebook flexing and
all that and a few other things which
we'll get into shortly but first here's
a look at that reunion at the airport
[Music]
that is her
[Music]
oh cute i wonder was that romantic drop
your bags and run moment organic or the
producer's idea i want to do that one
day
but knowing me
i'll be thinking about how dirty that
airport floor is
drop bags where
[Music]
all i saw was her travel pillow hit the
ground
so excited to come here it's been like a
dream come true it's finally it's it's
finally here
right when bilal and shaida hit the door
to head to the car
it didn't take long for his material
possessions to come up i just want to
just
get to know him all over again to be
quite honest and just get more
acquainted with one another
i'm looking forward to see a lot of
things you know he has been hiding from
me let's be real
so i'm looking forward to going home
seeing his house in his car
oh bellow's face says it all
i understand her excitement for wanting
to see how he lives and all of that but
i think it's the way she said it i'm
looking forward to going home seeing his
house in his car
that makes it a bit of a red flag
and seeing his house is one thing but to
emphasize seeing his car
you can think it but
why say it
you're telling on yourself speaking of
cars before we get into shota's reaction
to balau's rental van
take a look at how she reacts when she
thinks they're about to get into the
chevrolet that's parked next to the van
right here we are
[Music]
you take this
yeah did she get sad
[Music]
yeah
huh
what car does she drive in trinidad
that's what i want to know she laughed
at the chevy she was literally so
relieved to know that that wasn't his
car
but it didn't take her too long to start
complaining about the van well you
didn't put all you didn't put my things
in all this trash what's that you didn't
put my things in all this trash what are
you my mom
this is trash you put my bag inside
there like that that's not trash this is
trash
i think i see a little rock or something
that is my toolbox what are you talking
about
this place looking like something on
silence he was only trying to help you
for those who don't know samford and sun
is a classic tv show and as you can see
the house is full of clutter it is just
day one of bilal and shaida being
together and i can already see that this
is about to be a recurring theme here
it's not what you say let's say it all
together but it's how you say it it's
okay to be disappointed but that's no
excuse to be mean and nasty
bilal has always been secretive it sort
of worried me i was like what is he
hiding what does he have to hide
but just the mere fact that he's
flipping houses and buying property
i know that's cost a lot of money so i
know that his finances has to be as a
surgeon up there and that is not the
type of man expect him to drive
i'm not sure what she truly meant by
that but
it came off entitled
he's the one out here working hard at
making the money so what you think he
should drive is
irrelevant and if we want to talk about
real wealth here there are a lot of
wealthy people that drive average cars
they might have their luxury rides but
on a day-to-day basis you can find them
in a toyota camry i've seen it
i don't want to get into my training
behavior and start to
behave like a trainee you know we start
to say bad things and we'd be wild yeah
that wouldn't be a good thing
but this is completely unacceptable
[Music]
i love you being but you need three
points
you kind of lost little points for me
i'm a firm believer about appreciating
what you have
because here's the thing about life
things happen all the time you know i
know people who've had wealth and they
lose it
and they have to go back to their humble
beginnings like let's say if something
like that would happen like was she the
type person to still be ride or die for
you
because we are just meeting shaida for
the first time
i want to give her some grace i'm hoping
that as the show continues we'll start
to see more of her positive qualities
but as of right now i'm not getting rid
or die vibes mainly because of the way
she talks to him
but this is completely unacceptable
think about it if he was really down and
out what's she saying could break his
spirit and in a relationship you need
someone who's going to speak life into
you during those moments
i was hoping that you know she would be
a little like oh wow like this is your
car
okay you know i didn't think that it
would go the way that it went also to be
fair i'm not making any excuses for rude
behavior but if balal is flexing on
social media and showing off his
material possessions as if that is where
his worth lies
can he really get mad at her for valuing
his material possessions too
we are
home fast forward to when they get to
the house
shot of the shade queen comes out full
force
a home from the 1900s
must be an antique it's called historic
oh
all right
hey
so this is obviously everyone this is
where we watch tv at and stuff like that
um
pray man that's feeling
yeah i gotta get that done it looks like
it could collapse on us any moment
i'm just gonna insert really quickly
here
the house is a bit extreme
with all the work that needs to be done
on it and how the ceiling is peeling can
be concerning especially if it wasn't
something you were expecting
the truth is in most situations the way
someone keeps up their living space can
tell you a lot about them so i'm not
going to sit here and act like my mouth
wouldn't have dropped like shy's did
if i walked into that house knowing it
was about to be mine for the foreseeable
future this place
is dilapidated
this place is not the place i want to be
at after bilal gives her a tour of the
house this is where the magic happens
right in here okay
they sit down and have an honest
conversation
i was not expecting this
[Music]
expecting this right here yeah
is there any rocks in the kitchen
do i look like a person well the ceiling
is falling right now i don't even know
who are you because you showed up in a
panorama
i am not comfortable
moving to a first world country like
united states and having to live like if
i'm in the nineteen hundreds
we can you can do better we can when did
you read in the quran where it says you
need to provide a mansion i didn't ask
for an einstein okay that's the point
i'm making mm-hmm there are some things
that need to be fixed yes right however
well yeah i mean there's a lot of things
that need to be fixed with your attitude
right now too
bilal goes on to say that he's hurt by
the way shaida is reacting to the house
because it's actually his family's home
she came across say hey like the home i
understand it's a nice small house it's
comfortable etc but maybe we can grow
and get a big or something like that's
okay with me
but a lot of what she said was actually
more hurtful in relation to like i
thought that like you would have been
better than what you are right now
meanwhile she says the house does not
reflect the man who she fell in love
with nothing about this house says you
you know this is a reality check for
single ladies out there some of the men
you're counting out might really have it
all
no i'm just kidding believe what you see
until you're given a reason to think
differently
you want something to eat
yeah something that's from a clean bowl
yeah
yeah well i can order something
i know you don't want to eat you have
enough money for that that was not nice
wow you put a camera in front of some
people
and that still doesn't make them hold
their tongue
i get it she's disappointed but she's
showing her true character by how she's
choosing to act on her disappointment if
i was below and they make it through
this i don't know how i would feel about
spending money on her in the future i
would be hesitant i understand she has
standards but come on shaida
she has to make sure she doesn't block
her blessings by being too superficial
because if she's not careful that's
exactly what she's about to do
all the food is here yeah food is here
when milan came to trinidad he seemed
like a pretty much put together type of
guy you know he had louis vuitton
luggage
he dressed really nice stuff up
so i was expecting the home to kind of
suits how he looks shadow goes on to say
she feels deceived by bilal
and she tells him she feels like he's
struggling and that has her worried but
once chada sees that her behavior has
balaal and his feelings she softens up a
bit
just a bit
we might have to sell a couple of those
suits and i'm here to work with him and
so we have a lot of work to do before we
could even cross the bridge of getting
married
i just don't go with the image that you
carry yeah
then i and you can't you cannot fight me
don't be in shock
well you keep saying an image what is it
curry baby came to try and never get a
little bit on baggage
where inexpensive watches and belts
and delta common i mean in this little
humble abode it just it's not
how do you say it it doesn't suit you
well at least she's being honest about
how she feels
but it's wild because she has no clue
that what she wants he has
i definitely wouldn't want to marry
somebody who just wants me for my money
i rather for 100 for sure want to marry
somebody who wants me for what i am
speaking of that back to the question i
asked you earlier
if you had to choose between true love
that last key words that last or
financial wealth that last
what would your choice be
what really matters to you money or love
i know it's pretty obvious that i'm
going to say true love
how would i look saying financial wealth
after everything i said this episode but
don't get me wrong i plan to be
financially wealthy as a matter of fact
i am financially wealthy claim it yes
but while money is great to love and be
loved back
it's such an enriching feeling that
money can't buy
yes y'all better listen to teddy a
healthy love will motivate you to be
your best
carry you through life's challenging
moments and make the beautiful ones even
more beautiful
i know i sound like a sap but there are
rich people who after they have their
fun they're miserable and lonely because
they have no one to share their wealth
with on the other end you have people
who are genuinely in love and not rich
but happy
[Music]
all right i can't wait to hear your
thoughts but getting back to the couple
who inspired this conversation next week
bilal is taking shatter to where he
actually lives now i'm assuming he's
going to tell her
this was all a test this is a test we
gotta eat lunch over at my mom's house
will you still be with me if she doesn't
like me uh probably more than likely not
we have been arguing non-stop is this
the best time to meet his mom
[Music]
i can't wait to see her reaction
by the way i'm hopefully talking to
these two soon so if you have any
questions drop them in the comments and
i will pick a few
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]